TO THE MORINSKI. NYQUIST.
GETS HIS HEAD UP AND IS UP.
OVER THE HEIGHT, BUT --
>> Referee: IT OFF THE RIGHT SE
OF THE NET AND HUTTO
WHAT A NICE MOVE BY ALEXANDRE
TEXIER.
A
BLOCKER OF BROSSOIT.
TO
KEEGAN KOLESAR. CHANGES FOR THE
PLUNGES. IS LEFT ALL
AND JAKE BEAN BACK TO GET IT.
FORMER FIRST ROUND PICKK
DADONOV
TRYING TO FIGHT THROUGHAME.
NICE
AND KEEGAN KOLESAR SCORES!
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS
PLAYERS.
AND A GOOD JOB TONIGHT SCORE.
>> Dave: ROY GOODOMES JANMARK.
HE'S STOOD ALL ALONE.
WHAT
WENT OVER THE CROSS BAR.
>> Dave: WHITECLOUD LOO FEEDS I.
PIETRANGELO'S SHOT OFF THE BUT
HE HOOKS FIVE-SOME.
STONE KEEPS IT IN.
MERZLIKINS GETS A CROSS WITH THE
BLOCKER.
A GREAT PLAY AND WERENSKI. BLOCR
SIDE ONHE COLUMBUS POWER PLAY.
>> Dave: 45 SECONDS TO GO. OF AT
UP THE ICE. COLUMBUS.
DOWN TO WERENSKI.
7-0 THE SHOTS FOR VEGAS IN
COLUMBUS.
THERE'S ANOTHER BROKE HIS STICK!
MATTIAS JANMARK LINE.
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS GRAB THE 3-2
LEAD.
>> Dave: OBVIOUSLY IF THIS GOES
AGAINST THE BLUEION.
>> Referee: AFTER REVIEW, IT'S
BEEN TIME.